Rock, paper, scissors is an ancient
game of cunning and chance.
If only there was a way to improve
those chances.
Turns out there are a few
key strategies.
The game is mainly about predicting
and reading your opponent.
So what if you could predict
their first hand?
Research has shown
that there is a slight preference
for people to begin by playing rock.
There are different theories
about why -
it could be because
it is mentioned first
in the name of the game,
or it could be because
rock is similar to a fist
which seems powerful.
So if we know that, it gives us
an edge - just play paper.
Research shows that people who lose
a hand tend to change.
So there is a reasonable chance
that our opponent
will change to scissors or paper.
That gives us our second edge -
just play scissors and we should
either win or draw.
But this isn't an exact science.
What if it doesn’t go to plan
and your opponent wins?
Perhaps they know
a bit of game strategy too.
If we lost the previous hand
then our opponent might
reasonably expect us to switch
to something else.
This gives us our final edge -
surprise them by sticking
with our previous choice.
Hopefully they'll switch,
expecting us to switch,
and it should improve our chances.
The less predictable you are, the
better chance you have of winning.
Thanks for watching! :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!